de interpretar algunos de los mejores modelos masculinos de la historia
representados en la televisión.
Pueden reconocerme como "Escolta masculina #1".
(Risas)
"Violador en cita de fotógrafo",
"Violador en cita sin camisa"
"Ataque de tiburón en vacaciones de primavera".
(Risas)
"Estudiante de medicina sin camisa",
"Hombre sin camisa que toma esteroides"
y, en mi papel más conocido, como Rafael.
(Aplausos)
Un playboy melancólico y reformado
que se enamora, ante todo, de una virgen,
y que ocasionalmente está sin camisa.
(Risas)
Estos roles no representan el tipo de hombre que soy en mi vida real,
pero eso me encanta la actuación.
Puedo vivir dentro de personajes muy diferentes a mí.
Pero cada vez que realicé uno de estos roles, me sorprendió
porque la mayoría de los hombres que interpreto rezuman machismo,
carisma y poder,
y cuando me miro en el espejo, no es así como me veo a mí mismo.
Pero fue como Hollywood me vio,
y con el tiempo, noté un paralelismo
entre los roles que interpreto como hombre
tanto en pantalla como fuera de ella.
He estado fingiendo ser un hombre que no soy en mi vida.
He estado fingiendo ser fuerte, cuando me sentía débil,
confiado cuando me sentía inseguro
y duro cuando realmente algo me dolía.
Creo que en general he estado haciendo un show,
pero estoy cansado de jugar papeles.
Y puedo decir ahora que es agotador
intentar ser lo suficientemente hombre para todo el mundo todo el tiempo.
Bien, ¿correcto?
(Risas)
Mi hermano escuchó eso.
Desde que tengo uso de razón me han dicho
el tipo de hombre que debería ser.
De niño, solo deseaba ser aceptado y querido por los otros chicos,
pero esa aceptación significaba que tenía que adquirir
esa opinión casi asqueada de lo femenino,
y como nos dijeron que lo femenino es lo opuesto a lo masculino,
o tuve que rechazar la incorporación de cualquiera de estas cualidades
o enfrentarme yo mismo al rechazo.
Este es el guión que nos han dado.
¿Cierto? Las niñas son débiles y los niños son fuertes.
Esto es lo que se inculca subconscientemente
a cientos de millones de niños y niñas de todo el mundo,
tal y como me lo inculcaron a mí.
Hoy vine aquí a decir, como hombre,
que esto está mal, que es tóxico
y debe terminar.
(Aplausos)
No estoy aquí para dar una lección de historia.
Es probable que todos sepamos cómo llegamos aquí, ¿está bien?
Pero solo soy un tipo que despertó tras 30 años y se dio cuenta
de que estaba viviendo en un estado de conflicto,
conflicto entre quien siento que soy en mi fuero interno,
y entre quien el mundo me dice que debería ser como hombre.
Pero no tengo el deseo
de encajar en la actual definición rota de masculinidad,
porque no solo quiero ser un buen hombre,
quiero ser un buen ser humano.
Y creo que la única forma en que puede suceder
es si los hombres aprenden no solo a abrazar las cualidades
que nos dijeron que eran femeninas en nosotros mismos
sino a estar dispuestos a ponerse de pie,
para defender y aprender de las mujeres que los encarnan.
Ahora, hombres,
(Risas)
no digo que todo lo que hemos aprendido sea tóxico, ¿sí?
No digo que haya algo inherentemente malo en Uds. o en mí,
y hombres, no estoy diciendo que tengamos que dejar de ser hombres.
Pero necesitamos equilibrio, ¿sí?
Necesitamos equilibrio.
Y las cosas solo cambiarán si miramos honestamente
los guiones que nos han transmitido
de generación en generación
y los roles que, como hombres, elegimos asumir
en nuestra vida cotidiana.
Y hablando de guiones,
el primer guión que obtuve vino de mi padre.
Mi papá es increíble.
Él es amoroso, amable, sensible, enriquecedor,
él está aquí.
(Aplausos)
Está llorando.
(Risas)
Pero, lo siento, papá, de niño me enojaba por eso,
porque lo culpé por educarme blando,
lo que no era bien recibido en la pequeña ciudad de Oregon
a la que nos habíamos mudado.
Porque ser blando significaba que me estaban intimidando.
Miren, mi papá no era tradicionalmente masculino,
por eso él no me enseñó a usar mis manos.
Él no me enseñó a cazar, a pelear,
ya saben, esas cosas de hombre.
En cambio, él me enseñó lo que sabía:
que ser un hombre era sacrificio
y hacer lo posible
para cuidar y mantener a su familia.
Pero aprendí otro rol de la actuación de mi padre,
que lo aprendió de su padre,
un senador estatal
que más tarde en la vida
tuvo que trabajar de noche como conserje para mantener a su familia,
y nunca se lo dijo a nadie.
Ese papel fue sufrir en secreto.
Y ahora tres generaciones después,
me encuentro jugando ese papel, también.
Y ¿por qué mi abuelo no podía simplemente acercarse a otro hombre
y pedir ayuda?
¿Por qué mi padre todavía piensa que tiene que hacerlo todo solo?
Conozco a un hombre que preferiría morir
que decirle a otro hombre que está sufriendo.
Pero no es porque solo seamos todos tipos fuertes y silenciosos.
No es eso. Muchos de nosotros hombres somos muy buenos haciendo amigos
y hablando simplemente sobre nada real.
(Risas)
Si se trata de trabajo, deportes, política o mujeres,
no tenemos problemas para compartir nuestras opiniones,
pero si se trata de nuestras inseguridades o luchas,
nuestro miedo al fracaso,
entonces es casi como si nos paralizáramos.
Al menos, yo lo hago.
Entonces, algunas de las formas que he estado practicando
para liberarme de este comportamiento
están creando experiencias que me fuerzan a ser vulnerable.
Entonces, si hay algo donde experimento vergüenza en mi vida,
me sumerjo directamente en ello,
no importa cuán aterrador sea
y, a veces, incluso en público.
Porque al hacerlo
le quito su poder,
y mi despliegue de vulnerabilidad
en algunos casos, puede dar a otros hombres permiso para hacer lo mismo.
Como ejemplo: hace un tiempo
luchaba con un problema en mi vida
y sabía que necesitaba hablar con mis amigos,
pero estaba tan paralizado por el miedo
de que me juzgaran, de que me vieran como débil
y de perder mi posición de líder
que sabía que debía sacarlos de la ciudad en un viaje de tres días para chicos.
(Risas)
Solo para ganar confianza. ¿Y adivinen qué?
No fue hasta el final del tercer día
que finalmente encontré la fuerza para hablar con ellos
sobre lo que estaba pasando.
Pero cuando lo hice, sucedió algo asombroso.
Me di cuenta de que no estaba solo,
porque mis muchachos también habían estado luchando.